the anger
and tension over cashmere is growing
tempers are fraying
and there's immense frustration over
what's perceived to be the international
community's muted reaction over what's
going on there
this is what happens when the whole
issue of kashmir is raised it inflames
passions and people are prepared to go
to all sorts of lengths
many here want the pakistan government
to be tougher and containing this
thirst for justice may become
increasingly difficult for the different
political leaders
so we are angry here we don't want to
fight but i think that the last step
does option is to fight we have to get
the kashmir by sword by
ammunitions and guns and do you think it
people would support pakistan military
action
do you think the public here would yes
sure i am sure
pakistani people will support military
action what modi is doing he has
promised his people
that he will take over kashmir even
through unfair ways
he's basically massacring everything
the disputed territory is still mostly
under lockdown
with some communications relaxed ahead
of the muslim religious holiday of
eid thousands of troops are still
patrolling the streets
and hundreds of activists politicians
and academics have been rounded up and
arrested
to try to stop mass protests or
demonstrations
[Music]
the curfew was lifted briefly for
prayers but the largest mosque in
srinagar remained
closed for fear of large groups massing
and many here still feel
under a state of siege the pakistan
government has been in emergency mode
with imran khan's cabinet
meeting to agree an action plan they
want an emergency un security council
meeting
and a united front against what they say
is india's illegal moves
the country's top foreign minister made
an urgent trip to beijing
china has expressed serious concern over
what's been happening in kashmir
and both countries believe india's
unilateral decision
threatens the region's peace and
stability
they've been demonstrations too in india
with many critics of the country's
hard-line prime minister
seeing his move as unconstitutional and
provocative
so far the pakistan authorities are
pursuing political legal and economic
measures against india
but passions are high over kashmir and
no one believes it's going to be sorted
quickly alex gorford sky news islamabad